Lundi 6 novembre, c'était vraiment juste une
journée normale, je ne sais pas comment le
décrire autrement ce doigt de poulet lundi,
ces choses sont sacrément bonnes vraiment dans
ce déjeuner, je savais que quelque chose
n'allait pas, ça ne m'a pas vraiment frappé tout de suite et puis
ça  m'a vraiment frappé la limonade était
contaminée la plupart d'entre nous ont juste chié notre
pantalon ou devant tout le monde les
gens essayaient juste de trouver un endroit
où ils peuvent chier c'était la pire
chose que j'ai vue en 20 ans le fort était
partout il avait un  nom qu'il a sorti en
avril 2016,
Sam Eklund et moi avons commencé à tourner des vandales américains,
la réponse a été incroyable,
mais avec toute cette attention, il y a eu beaucoup
de pression que le type d'affaire à
prendre ensuite, je vous contacte parce que
nous avons un  vandale il s'appelle le
cambrioleur d'étron je regarde mon téléphone et
j'ai été tagué dans une vidéo de ce type voulait
un public il nous
narguait  avait un mu  ltiple et
qui pourrait être un suspect et
si le motif est juste du caca c'est drôle
c'est drôle c'est du caca mais ça va beaucoup
plus loin que ça
qui est le cambrioleur
[Musique]
toi